hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmccontrolra.l2-3.11.1 periodically
assess the risk to organizational
operations including the mission
functions image or reputation
organizational assets and individuals
resulting from the operation of
organizational systems and the
associated processing storage or
transmission of cui what a mouthful
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all this cmmc
dfars and nist SP 1001 compliance stuff
on top of an already colossal workload
well I've got great news you found your
home here at on-call compliance
Solutions where we can help you
transform into your company's on-call
compliance Hero Let's jump into it so
there's no getting around it this
control has a lot of big words okay and
if you're like me sitting at a third
grade reading level all I can say is
hang on I think my team gave us a
breakdown of what this actually means in
like somewhat plain English so basically
where we are going with this is into the
area of risk management we all know that
at the heart of nist SP 100 once in one
there's a lot of risk management Focus
now if you're an I.T guy at risk
Management's on the periphery but it may
not be your main thing and if you're an
attorney well then you know risk
management may be a little move a more
familiar subject and if you're a CEO hey
man risk that's like why I started my
business right taking big giant risks uh
managing those risks not such uh not
such a talent anyway this is a great
example where uh we are mandated to
evaluate the risk of operating the
business itself all right that's what
this control is actually about it's
about evaluating the risk of operating
as it relates to cui in the building
this is a great example where we are
mandated evaluate the risk of operating
the business itself and how operating
the business may put cui at risk it's
actually a really great high level
summary control and if they would have
used some more basic words to be honest
I think more of us would have an easier
time understanding the intent here
rather than dive into the exact wording
though let's go stream what the
assessors are looking for on this one to
learn more so two things you're looking
for one is determine if the frequency to
assess risk uh to organizational
operations uh organizational assets and
individuals is defined so did we Define
the risk okay do we Define the frequency
of how we're going to assess the risk
um how do we solve this this is a great
question right so we actually created a
quarterly risk management standard
operating procedure okay so if you're a
client of ours we actually customize a
risk management procedure for your
organization to help you meet this
control right the answer on paper is
frequencies is quarterly with larger
annual reviews per the company risk
management policy sop okay it could be
less often it could be more often it
depends on the size of your company the
risk you're dealing with Etc that's
something we can definitely help you
figure out uh you know and again if
you're struggling on the risk management
side of this it's totally understandable
it's not until you get to really really
big organizations that risk management
really sort of becomes more normalized
risk to organizational operations
organizational assets and individuals
resulting from the operation of an
organizational system that processes
stores or transmits cui is assessed with
the defined frequency so in other words
do you have a policy about it okay cool
the policy says it should be assessed
quarterly uh then are you actually doing
that assessment quarterly and can we see
evidence that you are so it's
implemented see risk management meeting
notes and time stamps now again so
critical that you have some kind of
evidence that you actually had meetings
where you manage risk if you're not
doing that it's something you have to
start doing if you don't know how to do
it one of the coolest things we've
created over the last five six years in
dealing with nist is we've created a
virtual compliance officer service it's
so cool it allows us to come in and be
your compliance officer you only pay a
fraction of the of the cost so again if
you're looking at this and you're going
through I don't have bandwidth to do
this in my day there's no way I can
manage all of this risk the good news is
we're highly experienced Risk Managers
we do this every day and it's a part of
our workflow and we can literally sort
of mesh gears if you will and make this
something that's really easy to do in
your organization led by professionals
so hey at on-call we work with defense
contractors just like you who have had
this defars nist itar and cmmc
compliance stuff dropped in their laps
like a seal on a sunny day we teach you
how to level up and be a proper on-call
compliance hero for your company
eliminating gaps great areas and getting
this solved all while showing you how to
leverage compliance is your secret
weapon to land more Defense work with
higher profit margins now that's what
becoming an on-call compliance hero can
do for you looking for more help getting
compliant our compliance experts are
always on call for you visit cmmc
compliance secrets.com or check out the
bio below for links to get help right
now if you love the content we're
putting out here for you help us out
with a big thumbs up on that like button
or even better smash the Subscribe
button to get the latest compliance
content as soon as our compliance
centers roll it out until the next
Appliance tip my friends stay safe and
secure out there and hit us up in the
comments below if you would like to know
anything else about information security
and compliance and I'll see you on the
next one
[Music]
all right